demonstrations have been called across
Iran after a second a protester was
executed by the regime Majid Reza
ranavard was detained during
anti-government protests he was
convicted for allegedly stabbing two
security officers to death during
demonstrations human rights activists
say nearly 500 people have now been
killed in the Nationwide protest that
began in the middle of September a
estimate at least a dozen people are
facing the death penalty for taking part
in the protest movement
for more on this let's bring in Cameron
Martini he's a senior lecturer on
international relations at the
University of Sussex in Britain
um Cameron this is the second execute
execution in just uh two weeks after the
alleged offense uh are you surprised by
that quick and very brutal response
good morning Erhard no I'm not this was
expected and the regime has been laying
around for this um this killings which
by all conventions actually are
extrajudicial killings uh the person who
was executed this morning
was only arrested 23 days ago so the
whole process from arrest to execution
took only more a little more than three
weeks he had no access to Independent
lawyer it was a lawyer which was
determined by the by the state and in
fact an Iranian human rights lawyer
claims that given that there was no um
private plaintiff in this case I.E the
whole case was brought to the court by
the government and and actually
processed by the government by Judiciary
itself it's a sort of State killing
um and I should also add that there are
other protesters who are actually being
killed under torture in the prison but
the government then claims they have
been either committing suicide or they
had some other underlying conditions
including for example uh Mr shadman who
is a Kurdish protester who has been
recently the the body has been returned
to the to the family so the killings are
actually in prisons going in the
different ways but as we see and you you
mentioned the protests are already being
called against this and I I don't see
how this uh unbridled violence could
could actually end the protest because
it makes people
excuse me for interrupting you will it
discourage uh protesters if you risk
your life uh and and risk the death
penalty uh will it discourage protesters
I'm not sure it does because people who
go to the streets already prepared for
being actually shot at by Security
Forces something which the government
security troops have done for past three
months I mean you you mentioned in your
clip that in the beginning that more
than 460 people have already been killed
in the in the demonstrations majority of
which have been actually fired up by a
live ammunition during the process so I
think people are aware of
um of the um of the dangers and risks
and they are familiar with the practices
of the Islamic Republic against
opposition and I would also want to say
that in fact the protest or opposition
to these executions have reached the
highest level within the religious
authorities of Shia Islam itself in the
city of hum which is the center of Shia
kind of jurisprudence so the government
is is quite desperate in a way it's it's
a supposedly a show of force but I think
it shows more more desperation and fear
rather than actually Authority and
control
now this is a Grassroots movement there
aren't any any clear leaders How likely
do you think it is that they can bring
out real change even the regime change
in Iran
well I think
um this is both a kind of um a strength
but also potentially in short term at
least a weakness of the movement the
strengths because the regime cannot
easily find the leaders and and deal
with them and therefore bring the the
movement to an end and and weakness
because it it kind of um you know makes
it more difficult to act more
strategically to to be a source of kind
of an interlocutor for International
Community and so on and so forth but I
think these are the new kinds of
movement we see in the in the recent
times and Leadership would emerge from
within the movement over time and we're
already seeing the growth of labor union
Trade union student movements and so on
and I I think in the long run this might
be even better because it reduces the
possibility of external imposition of
particular kind of political program on
the movement as a whole but we have to
see um how how far and for how long the
movement can sustain the current Tempo
it has Cameron Martin from the
University of Sussex in Britain thank
you very much
thank you